starting february 12 there won't be a
mandatory limit for private gatherings
but we recommend to limit yourself to 10
people or three bubbles
we ask you to evaluate your risks
we need to learn to live with the virus
also on february the 12th restaurants
will have tables of 10 people or three
bubbles
starting february 14 we'll restart
restart sports matches outdoor shows
will also be allowed to host up to 5 000
people
starting february 21 all stores will be
allowed to operate at full capacity for
amphitheaters it will be 50 capacity and
for places of worship it will be 50
capacity with a maximum of 500 people
starting february 28th we'll restart
competitions and sport tournaments it
won't be mandatory to work from home
anymore
and fee
theaters and places of worship of
workship will reopen at full capacity
except for bell center and video center
and will reopen bars and casinos at 50
capacity without dance and karaoke
finally starting march 14 dance and
karaoke will be allowed restaurants bar
and large in theaters will reopen at
full capacity so after march 14 almost
all restriction will be lifted we're
talking uh taking a calculated risk to
learn to live with the virus and the
best way to live with the virus is to
get your treat doses of vaccine
no
we are asking
public health since few weeks now to
have a plan unfortunately until last
night
they told us that
they were there was too much uncertainty
to be able to table this kind of plan
but last night they said that
the risk is a calculated risk and we can
go
forward so
we were waiting for the okay of the
public but you saw this [ __ ]
okay sorry i cut you off
no but
of course like you in the last weeks i
would say since the beginning of january
we see that the population is fed up i'm
fed up we're all fed up so
i can understand but the reason why we
resist until today is because
there was too much risk
about the situation in our hospitals we
wanted to be sure that we'll be able to
take care of each patient